I'm continuing this series of channel
updates for my subscribers so that they
have some idea of what's going on this
month and what what I did last month I
get to fill them in on some of the
things I'm interested in or getting
entangled with or you know where I put
my efforts I'm a little bit behind this
month it's now September 11th that you
know that big day for for everybody
since the September 11th quite a while
ago I and well you'll find out why
waited so long this month as I tell you
about what August was like so August was
in some respects a month where I don't
feel like I got a ton of stuff done but
I seem to put a lot of effort into
things I was finishing up an online
10-week course in ethics that I was
teaching from marist college and that
drew to a close I thinking about the
beginning of the second week and then I
started prepping for my classes that
began at the end of august at marys I'm
teaching an ethics class which I've got
down pretty well but I always you know
tweak the material a little bit add some
stuff take some stuff out and then a new
intro to philosophy class with a totally
different theme totally different
readings from previous semesters I'll
tell you a little bit about that in a
moment so I have that stuff going on
class related stuff my wife had gone off
to Switzerland at the beginning of the
month to two European graduate school
where she's a doctoral student to do her
residency for that very exciting time
for her and it was kind of fun to see
from the sideline should give me you
know reports from time to time well this
guy talked about this and this woman
talked about this and here's what the
students were interested in and they get
a lot of really big name thinkers and
it's a it's got a strong focus on
continental philosophy you know sort of
cutting-edge stuff but they have some
interest in some classic continental
philosophy to particularly Heidegger so
that leads me into one of the things
that I actually did get done
in August one of the works that they are
particularly interested in over there at
EGS and understandably so because their
their emphasis is really on artistic
production and you know Media Studies
and that sort of thing is heidegger's sa
the origin of the work of art and since
my my wife was sort of grappling with
this for for the first time in a really
serious way and doing so with people who
are you know honest to god Heidegger
scholars I'm just somebody who who
teaches about Heidegger I don't do a lot
of scholarly work on Heidegger himself
but there are people who would just
specialize in in his thought I thought
it'd be nice to get the existentialist
series moving again that's laying fallow
for for a while while I recovered from
my leg injury by shooting a sequence of
videos on that particular work
heidegger's origin of the work of art so
I did shoot three hour long video
lectures where I go into the work
there's some facets of the essay that I
didn't cover but I think I and managed
to go over most of what's going on in
there lay on to outline it and I'm
hoping not necessarily this month but
maybe next month to put together some
some handouts on it as well that would
go along with with the videos so there
was that I did a guest spot on the radio
show theology matters with the Pell use
on Thomas Aquinas and natural law and
that was my second time doing that that
show I enjoyed it I had some interesting
calls come in including one guy who is
quite you know wound up and you know I
was raising some of the typical New
Atheists attacks which aren't actually
new they're all old stuff that's just
you know sort of recycled from the
eighteenth and nineteenth century in in
new form and and was very you know very
tendentious and
it was an interesting experience for me
because i am a tendency to like throw
myself into these these arguments and so
i try to keep myself back from that
because in the past I've been a little
bit too aggressive in those kind of
arguments and nothing ever useful comes
out of them people go into them
convinced and they come out of them
convinced and what I did is I sort of
SAT back and put it out to the guy that
the way that he was like choosing to set
things up and define things was already
sort of prejudice prejudicing prejudging
anyway structuring things in a
prejudicial way from the very beginning
so that any person who tried to respond
to them they write effect loaded
questions like when we say loaded
question we mean things like have you
quit beating your wife anyway you answer
the way the question is set up it's
going to be bad for you so in my eyes I
and this is sort of a sign of how things
are for me I not as developed as they
ought to be it felt like I had not
really you know answered the guy that I
the way I should have but but I got a
lot of positive feedback from people say
that was exactly the way to address that
that sort of caller so um yeah I did a
talking about natural law it was kind of
nice congenial for the most part what
else I did quite a few videos about like
phases in my philosophical development
some of the ones that I had started
doing back in in july i continued that
sort of thing forward i still have a lot
more of those yet to do and i'll put
those together in one playlist i started
doing something new which was taking the
vu two minute short videos that i have i
used to be on this this social network
called to you which is gone going boss
in about the last year and on this
social network you could respond to
other V users and like you know give
them questions or comments people from
the outside could shoot in questions and
comments as well and then here's what
was really distinctive about it your
response to those
shins or comments would be in the form
of a two-minute or under video recorded
from your webcam on your computer so I
mean as you can guess computer
technology has advanced a lot and
webcams have gotten a lot better so the
video quality on a lot of these clips is
not particularly good but I was
answering some interesting questions
that viewers are putting to me so when
vu went went boss they actually sent us
users us v users as we recalled all the
videos that we had generated for them
and so I thought yeah it'd be kind of
cool to put this stuff together and you
know offer to my YouTube subscribers and
my facebook page followers and you know
people that will follow me on Google+ or
Twitter and see what they make of this
stuff so I've been taking 10 videos at a
time that have to do with some sort of
common thing like maybe ethics or
religion or politics and then bundling
them together and editing and uploading
it I think what I'm going to do this is
sort of taking me into the what's coming
up in the future for September i'm just
going to still be bundling these
together because i've still got a number
of decades yet to to go to process to
upload but down the line so this is you
know something for maybe october
november december down the line what i'm
going to start doing is finding some way
to create a forum where my YouTube
subscribers and and Facebook followers
and other people who follow me on other
sites can write in and say hey I'd like
you to do a really short thing about
this question or this topic or what do
you think about this and then bundle
those together as 10 shorts so that
would be kind of I think that'd be kind
of a cool idea and I didn't come from me
it came from one of my my YouTube
subscribers who suggested that if i
remember right so that's something i'm
going to be doing um what else
that's pretty much it for August so
what's coming up this month in September
what's left is some tempura now that I'm
you know one third of the way through it
well I'm teaching classes at marist
college so I'm doing a lot of prep work
because I didn't have everything totally
set up from the start even the ethics
class which I've taught a number of
times and I've got a lot of material
already set up for I've got some new
material that I have to develop handouts
for you know create new assignments
generate some some new course you know
readings and things like that like this
this semester for example we're going to
read Plato's Republic book nine that's a
new edition and I dropped a few things
out that we had studied in previous
semesters we're also going to be reading
McIntyre's after virtue normally have
them read chapters 2 and 3 they're also
going to read chapters 14 and 15 towards
the end of the semester so you know I've
got some new things going on in the
intro to philosophy class we're doing a
lot of new material and you notice me
uploading some of that and putting it
into the intro playlist and also putting
it into some of the thinker playlists we
started out the semester with Plato's
lysias this is about friendship and
we're knee-deep right now in the
symposium which is a set of speeches
given at a drinking party about love in
which Socrates is involved with a lot of
other people you notice the common theme
right the common theme for this entire
semester for that class is love
friendship and desire so we're trying to
figure out how do these work what are
they how do they Italian with
metaphysics with ethics with philosophy
of nature with epistemology it gives the
course of really cool focus and it's
something that all my students I think
can relate to to some extent and since
philosophers especially ancient and
medieval philosophers had a lot to say
about these topics it's a chance for me
to go back and teach texts that
ordinarily I don't get too much of a
chance to talk about so what we've got
coming up the rest of the month one
we're done with play-doh i'm doing a
workshop session with them on close
reading papers because i'm going to do
that and then we're delving into
aristotle we're looking at aerosols
metaphysics particularly where he's
talking about desire and the final good
as motivating us and also his critiques
of some theories about love in there and
then we're looking at Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics some of the books in
that then we move to the epicurean
tradition we're going to spend one day
on that look at the curious talking
about friendship we're gonna have a
guest lecture in there in the semester
as well which I'll hopefully be able to
record and that takes me up today I
think about the end of the month so
that's what's going on with classes so
you can expect to see these class videos
being uploaded I'm going to keep on
doing the like I said the 10 short vu
videos on this and that now i'm mostly
dealing with things in religion and once
i'm done with that I'll turn to some of
the interesting critical thinking
argumentation questions that were given
to me I'm going to shoot some more core
concept videos as time permits I also
have to finish up the Aristotle
categories video series he didn't know
that it was the series globally shot one
of the videos so far I shot it before I
damaged by me which now is you know it's
not you know it's not fixed but I can
get around on it so now it's time for me
to finish up shooting all these videos
on the categories that I wanted to do
because you know it's a loose thread
that I want to tie up before the month
is over and then I want to start
shooting some of the existentialism
videos that I keep meaning to get to so
I've got some some time slots lined up
to shoot some videos about this really
cool existentialist thinker that not a
lot of people talk about Leon shestov
who was actually the first guy as far as
I know to see the connections between
Kierkegaard Dostoevsky and
nicha the three you know grandfather's
of existentialism and to talk about them
fanatically he also saw connections to
Tolstoy and check off and then some
other authors as well really cool
interesting under taught existentialist
thinker who I think is just as important
as Heidegger or Sarge or Marcel or kind
of move so I'm going to spend some time
talking about some of his really works
if I have the time I'm hoping also to
shoot some videos about Gabriella Marcel
and then we're going to hopefully get to
some other existentialist thinkers later
this semester I'm hoping also if I have
the time to shoot a video on hydrators
response to Sartre it starts
existentialism is a humanist of this
letter on humanism that hiding the road
because it's an important in
existentialist debate so I've got that
going on I'm spending a lot of time sort
of updating my my web presence you know
we it's easy to fall behind when you've
got so many different projects going on
I've been updating my learnist courses
if you're interested in learning it's
kind of a cool platform for you know
setting up many courses and that's what
I've been doing with it I've been
talking with a number of different web
platforms developers that are interested
in educational materials about producing
some content for them and so I'm looking
to do some of that material as well I
will talk more about that probably in
another video and you know I'm just
tidying things up here and there on
YouTube I'm trying to organize the
playlist a little bit more more
rationally and get everything in where
it ought to be
categorize things you know you end up
spending a lot of time not just
producing content but but what we call
curating content as well I also have two
other things going on this month that I
think viewers might be interested in
I'll have footage of one of them but not
of the other for the other one which is
the radio show theology matters you have
to go online and go to their actual site
you can get the podcast of it as a
matter of fact if you're interested in
the podcasts of my my previous two
sessions where I was a guest where he
talked about seeing handsome and Thomas
Aquinas on natural law go to their
little just type in theology matters
Pelaez and you'll you'll find their
their site it's on blog talk radio i
believe and you can you can download the
podcast anyway this month September 26
which is a thursday night i am going to
be on theology matters and i'm going to
be talking instead of talking about a
theistic Christian philosopher I'm going
to talk about somebody who is an atheist
you kind of kept it under wraps but a
lot of people suspected it at the time
and that's David Hume and I'm going to
talk mostly about Humes famous dialogues
on natural religion which is a text that
I taught last semester and videotaped
some some nice footage on but I'll talk
about some of hume's other ideas and his
effect on on theology and Christian
thought why he's such a serious opponent
and then we'll see what happens when
viewers call in if you if any of you who
want to call in you know any of you
watch my stuff in our interest in this
earth day i invite you to to call in to
the palace you can find all that stuff
on their website the other thing that
I've got going on is a little bit
different and it's something that I've
done something like this before in the
but the philosophy eats talk that I gave
a while back on hedonism which we did at
a restaurant and it was tied in with a
themed menu I gave a talk and it was
tied in with a menu that was deemed
about hedonism he is involved is all
about pleasure this one is going to be
at the Culinary Institute of America
it's on the 21st and it's part of their
feasting and foraging extravaganza day I
am not exactly sure I'm a little bit
hazy on some of the details at this
point but I know there's a lot of
different things that they've got
planned for their students and it's all
centered around this notion of feasting
and foraging so some of it has to do
with you know prehistoric peoples and
Flint rapping and all that the the thing
that I'm going to be doing is talking
about drinking parties namely symposia
symposium originally meant drinking
party in Greek you know the sum together
then podium is coming from the Greek
word drink and how did we get from
parties where people would hang out and
sometimes drink pretty heavy and do
drinking games and get involved in all
sorts of crazy things and sometimes give
speeches and make arguments to these
very abstract and strew seeeeee
non-drinking philosophical or you know
any other sort of field thing where
you've got a panel of experts all
dressed up in academic garb just talking
talking talking how do we go from this
fun thing to this kind of dry thing I'm
going to talk about that and it's going
to be a symposium because one of the
professor's is going to be bringing a
hard apple cider that he has brewed
himself he is a wine and beverage guy
who is just you know brilliant when it
comes to the history of alcoholic
beverages he knows all about in all the
different liquors and how they came to
be and so I'm really looking forward to
this collab
nation people are going to be enjoying
the apple cider well I'm doing a talk
and then doing some Q&A and back and
forth with them about symposia and
drinking parties and how we went from
here to here and how maybe we can get
back while we're actually involved in a
mini symposium on the site so that's
going to be pretty cool and we're going
to try to get footage of it so that
those of you who can't be there can in
some way participate maybe you know
raise a hard apple cider while you're
while you're watching it that's what
I've got going on this month now that I
actually talk about it it's quite a lot
of stuff and I probably should quit
shooting this video and start getting
out with my work so i'll leave you with
that